welcome back to the coffee with kennel
show the first coffee with channel of
2021 today's topic
is youtube analytics we're going to
start in just a second
in this show for the first 10 or 15
minutes
we break down some youtube strategies
that you can use to grow your influence
grow your income and make a greater
impact this year
and then i take your questions and even
bring on you as a guest to the show
so we can review your channel answer
your questions but if we're just meeting
my name is sean cannell cheers
let me know what you're drinking smash
the like button and let's get right into
this
i'm sipping some ethiopian coffee from
atomic coffee and today we're going to
be talking about youtube analytics
if you want to have a successful youtube
channel
you have to fall in love with data i
really believe that
what gets measured gets improved and in
this video i'm going to be sharing
10 analytics that i look at once a video
has been published
so i can understand how it performed and
how i can make
data-driven decisions so that my next
video
is hopefully my best video and i can get
more views more subscribers and even
earn more money we're going to talk
about that
of my future content because i'm
paying attention to the data so let's
get straight into it what you do
as you go into your youtube studio in
the back end and one of the ways you can
get to a specific video
is just do a search i'm going to look up
a video called amazing home office
design
ideas when you search it you can click
the little analytics
graphic right here and it takes you
straight to the video analytics
now this video we're going to be talking
about 10
analytics that we look out on a specific
video and number one
is how does this video compare to my
typical video
performance you can see this in a couple
ways right here on screen
you can see this little gray line and
the gray line is how the video typically
performs and if i hover on that that's
how the video typically performs
the blue line is showing that this video
is outperforming the typical performance
additionally it gives you a green arrow
right here and a green arrow here
on views and watch time to say that this
video is getting 62
000 views then more since published so
far
and on watch time and you can click that
to get another graph you can click
through these
tabs right here it also is up so this
video is crushing
so that's the first question i ask like
how is this video doing compared to
a typical video now a quick tip here
is this video was doing well kind of
from the start
but i've noticed a trend that videos are
breaking out
sometimes it takes a month 30 days
sometimes 45 days
60 days and so what's been interesting
is you have to have
patience and do the right things
good titles good thumbnails good content
and sometimes it takes a while
for a video to break out the second
question
is is this video gaining or losing
subscribers in this case
this one video has grown the think media
channel
by 759 subscribers so
far uh a lot of times sometimes going
live
um sometimes pointing at a video that
doesn't really resonate with your
audience might actually have a minus
subscribers there
you want to pay attention to that and
sometimes you still may be okay with it
because after
over time it might lose subscribers at
first eventually gain them later but you
should be paying attention
how's this content resonating with my
current subscribers
number three is key moments for audience
retention what are the key moments
for audience retention let me refresh
this i'll go full screen so you can see
it
now this is a very powerful graph
that actually shows where the content
is maybe losing attention if it's
holding attention it shows you spikes
notice this it says two spikes so these
two spikes right here are
probably people scrolling through
because what this video ultimately is
is a compilation of three different
office tours it's my office tour and by
the way if you're looking for some home
office upgrades and
you're looking for kind of how we do our
home offices you've got my office you've
got heather
taurus on the think media's team's
office then you have omar's office
so maybe someone starts watching they
kind of get bored they skip to the next
one
and there's also chapters so people can
find their way and skip through
but the one of the big things here is
again key moments for audience retention
and i'm asking myself
hey on my next video how can i
potentially do better
and what can i learn average percentage
viewed
matters if you can get over 50 of the
people
finishing the video that can be a great
thing or if you can crack
seven eight nine minutes that also can
be very powerful
you know this is a 30 minute video so
it's a much longer video
and it is being massively recommended by
the youtube algorithm right now
so um it is definitely performing well
uh number four is how is the video
performing in real time views on the
right side of the screen here
we're now looking at real time views
every two days this video is getting
around 4 365 videos and in the last 60
minutes
this video has gotten 98 views we're on
the right side of the screen over here
i'll go full screen and zoom in so you
can see it maybe a little better
it's on the right side real time views
browse features is the top traffic
source that means that this video
is being shown on the home page a little
bit of youtube search a little bit of
external little bit of suggested
but browse is really the main traffic
source
so when this video shows up on people's
home
pages the thumbnail is very clickable
the topic is maybe interesting
and so long as it gets clicked on and
then people spend seven minutes
of their time on average watching this
video the video continues
to be recommended and so um
super powerful now we're going to get
into the next few tips in a second but
today's coffee with kennel
episode is brought to you by
our brand new limited time think master
class this is a
updated class that's only available for
a limited time and i'm actually going to
be going into how i use one simple
youtube strategy
to turn 130 dollars into over 19 323
with a single youtube video link in the
description down below if you want to
register
i haven't really shared this anywhere in
this depth
and if you like these 10 tips on
analytics i'm going to be specifically
going super deep
on how to earn money from youtube not
with youtube adsense i'm going to show
you how i spent 130
what i did after that when it comes to
youtube and creating
a video and exactly how that investment
generated 19 323 dollars it's going to
be super fun
and so if you want to register for that
link in the description
down below and let's keep going with our
youtube analytics
tips number five is what are the traffic
sources so now up top here you've we're
on the overview page of a single video
and in a future video
we'll talk about channel analytics
reviewing your internet analytics for
the last 30 days 90 days we're just
reviewing 10 analytics of one upload
about 40 days after the video came out
so now i want to know
this is the overview page i'm going to
click on reach here
this is going to give me some new data
the next question i'm asking number five
is what are the traffic sources
so as i scroll down there's this really
important graph right here what are the
traffic sources we discovered that
browse features
73 of the views are coming from browse
features if i hover over this little i
it tells me what the traffic source is
and so this traffic source is home page
home screen views also subscription feed
and other browsing features so great so
this video is really generating from
traffic sources
furthermore on this right side here it's
actually really powerful to see
impressions and how they led to watch
time 76
of these impressions have come from
youtube recommending
my content now how do you influence that
it says you can increase the chance of
youtube suggesting your content
by increasing your click-through rate
and your view video
watch time so click through rate is a
little low
2.7 but the average view duration the
video watch time is 7 minutes and 21
seconds so
youtube is like man that's that's a lot
of time on platform we're going to
recommend this video
so i like to check my traffic sources i
like to see where impressions are coming
from
and i like to look at the click-through
rate now back up top here
on the reach tab of a single video
inside of my analytics
i'm clicking on impress impressions
click through rate and you can actually
see
as the video has been released day after
day
what kind of uh click-through rate has
it been getting and it's been
2.8 3.1 you know a good click-through
rate is over 10
if you can get over 15 or 16 and hold
that you basically have a viral video on
your hands
now this might be a niche topic a little
bit with home office design ideas maybe
the length that's kind of intimidating
to click on a 30-minute video
so really if your click-through rate is
high
and your average view duration is high
then you're gonna have
a banger on your on your hands you're
gonna hack the youtube algorithm and
blow it up
if one of those two things is high
you're also gonna blow it up so
that's what i like to uh definitely see
what's the click-through rate what can i
learn from next time
i think the thumbnail is pretty
phenomenal i think that the
title is also very good but the topic
may not have been as widely interesting
to our subscribers and here's the
interesting thing
is again like if you got if you got a
breakout video like this blue line right
here that looks like it's not going to
stop
i mean live with it like that's great
but always asking man how can i make
that higher
and in in my opinion topic would be
probably the biggest influence of that
not necessarily title and thumbnail
because i think both of those are strong
number seven i'm going to ask what's the
average view duration now we've asked
that
but we're going to go to the next tab
over that's engagement
and we have our total watch time hours
10 800
watch time hours and i want to encourage
you naturally this was released on a
large channel
that already had big influence it took a
long time to build that influence
um you know you got to start before
you're ready start messy
start posting videos and build your
channel one subscriber at a time
but i think this also shows the power of
even just one video if you want to get
monetized
get a thousand subscribers get four
thousand hours of watch time this one
video
has a ca has accomplished that result
and it's also 30 minutes long so
remember you're always one video away
from potentially reaching
your next youtube goal and if you put
out the right video at the right time
with the right title and the right
thumbnail with the right content
then you can see incredible things
happen
so next though i want to ask about
average view duration this is a huge
metric like the two big levers are
click-through rate and average view
duration
this one has three minutes and 31 min uh
seconds more than usual as far as the
performance
and you actually can see the gray line
here of my typical performance on the
think media youtube channel
is around 3 minutes and 53 seconds to
about you know
4 minutes and 30 seconds and then the
pink line is how this video is
performing and how much time people
spend watching this video
so again this is the metric if you're
curious man how do i hack the algorithm
this is the metric on this video that
led to the result
people are spending seven minutes and 37
seconds of their hard
one time hanging out on this video
not watching the expanse on amazon prime
not watching queen's gambit on netflix
seven minutes and 37 seconds and and
that's average view duration
right so some of course are spending
longer and that's holding the
average viewer that clicks on this video
is spending that much time so
huge metric that you want to think about
how do i increase that
and let's get to number eight so now
we're going to click audience
and this one's not talked about a lot
but this one
is the average views per viewer see it
says right here
the average views per viewer so
the average views per viewer is the
average number of times a viewer watched
this particular video in this period so
the question i'm asking is how many
videos does the average viewer watch
this is just off this video this is one
that i want to increase and that can
really help your channel what does it
mean
it means that if somebody clicks on one
of your videos do they watch
a second a third or fourth the fifth do
they stay on your channel and watch 10
videos
if you can increase that average views
per viewer number
it really can be a game changer you know
one in this case it people barely watch
too
and if they find this video maybe their
mindset may be suggested maybe getting
distracted maybe ending their viewing
session
they're not necessarily binging a whole
bunch of different videos
um a way to see how this really works
well would be like one of my favorite
youtube channels called daily dose of
the internet
they have a couple smart things going
for them one
their youtube videos are very short
three four minutes
two they really pull fair use content
from a lot of places and they
consolidate like really entertaining
clips
three they're kind of just pleasant
entertaining low
mental fatigue watchable videos
but also because they're short i'll
oftentimes play one
on my smart tv when we're making dinner
or something and then suggest it to me
is the second third fourth or fifth
because maybe it takes 25 minutes to
prepare dinner so
we watch like five or six of them and
they're super entertaining it plays me
old ones because it comes
out daily so i wouldn't be surprised if
their average view per viewer
is like 5 views or 10 or a lot more
so to me that is are you creating
content
that somebody could watch one video
love it and then want to do a bingeable
session on your channel be like that was
awesome they want to watch another one
in some cases think media creates
searchable content
one problem one answer type of content
and the viewing session might end
but whatever possible if you can create
kind of bingeable viewing sessions
that can be super powerful and that is a
metric that i like to look at
if you're getting value smash like we're
going to get into the last three tips
here
and number nine is what is my cpm
so we can see now we're going to click
the revenue tab we're studying one video
and we're going through these 10
questions i like to ask about every
video
what's my click-through rate what's my
average view iteration what are the
traffic sources
how are the real-time views doing now
we're talking about money
so what is the cpm so the cpm of this
video is 23.64 cents now this is a
remarkable
because if you want to make money from
youtube ads you know
a lot of times the average cpm
is one to five dollars on youtube
so this means how many
uh how much you're gonna make cpm stands
for cost per mil
and mill or milli is a roman term for a
thousand
and it means that if ads play
you're gonna make 23.64 now a huge
misconception though
is that is not how much money you
actually keep um
that is the total amount amount of money
earned by the video but youtube takes 45
of that and you keep 55 of that your rpm
is a much more accurate number that is
exactly how much money you earn
this number also could be pushed up
because
of super chats which you act which could
be a lot if you were doing if you were
getting super chats or
uh people that are kind of tipping you
because they're grateful for your
content
so this is socially essentially tells me
that every 1000 monetized
views and and what do i mean by monetize
well maybe an ad doesn't play
maybe somebody has an ad blocker uh it
actually the ad has to be planed and
seen you could scroll down and see that
uh skippable ads are the main source a
little bit of bump
bumper ads and a few other things but
the main ones the the bumper ads
and the skippable ads but all that to
say
is number nine what is my cpm and number
10 what is my rpm
i like to know how much money
is a video earning not just how much has
it earned so far
this video is generated at the time of
recording this 881 dollars and 60 cents
but how much money um is
this compared to maybe another video on
my channel
and the way you influence this it has a
lot to do with topic and audience
what country is your audience watching
in how old is your audience
and what is your audience's mindset is
it professional audience
is it business owners real estate
investors venture capitalists
entrepreneurs small business owners
the creator economy like what is it or
is it like
kids that want to you know 14 year olds
that want to watch cat videos
it can affect how much advertisers are
willing to pay to get in front of your
audience
secondly though it's really topic so
home office design ideas
talking about maybe tech home office
versus
a pranks channel or maybe a gaming video
or something else
this is these are the types of things
that cover that affect your cpm
and therefore your rpm so uh
in certain cases you may want to create
videos about strategic types of topics
some of the highest
cpm niches are things like real estate
investing personal finance tech is kind
of in the middle it's not one of the
high ones
medical a lot of medicine doctors
uh biohackers health tips that can be a
high
cpm niche and then you experiment over
time and you want to of course stay on
brand
stay in your niche but the selection of
what niche you have on youtube
could be influenced by your ambitions
when it comes to earning money from your
youtube channel and also the one-off
topics
for think media we help people with the
best tips and tools for building their
influence with online video
this is obviously the gear and tech side
how do you build out your home office
and your battle station
um and we've noticed that sometimes when
you talk about money
it usually drives your cpm up if it was
like how to make money on youtube that
might be a little bit higher
and then maybe something else that is
just something about software although
software is
is pretty high as well and so um all of
that are really good
questions to ask and when i'm asking
that i'm also curious how much money
has this video generated you know to
look at one other video on the channel
there is uh this video right here how to
get this was actually a live stream
but it's how to get 1 000 subscribers
fast on the think media channel
and you can actually see the power of
one video this video has generated
almost a million views
twenty five thousand new subscribers
sixteen thousand five hundred and ninety
one dollars
and we can see the cpm was thirty three
dollars and again the rpm is
usually about half that 17.76
so not only is it higher but then you
multiply that by the views over time
and that's a pretty good amount of money
earned
from just this one video
so if you have uh if you got value out
of this video hit the like button and i
want to remind you
that today's coffee with cannel is
brought to you by
our brand new uh exclusive
web class where i'm going to be breaking
down how i use one simple youtube
strategy
to turn 130 dollars into over 19 323
with a single video now i'm actually not
really talking about adsense we just
showed you
cpm and rpm this is not that this is
actually other monetization strategies
connected to some smart youtube strategy
you're going to love it if you want to
watch this
it's where i go a little bit deeper it's
an hour long free class
link in the description down below or
you can just go to thinkmasterclass.com
to be a part of the training and go to
that website to register
for free but friends this is
the coffee with cannell show my name is
sean cannell
and i'm so fired up i hope your year is
going good so far let me know what
you're drinking where you're watching
from and if you have a question
type four question marks before and
after your question
we're also going to drop the link on
facebook and youtube if you want to join
and we'll bring some people on the show
a little bit later
but i hope you're doing well it's been a
busy year we have not uh done a coffee
with kennel or think marketing live
this year yet and so heather taurus is
going to be back
bi-weekly i'll be back bi-weekly that
means every other week
and and you will have a show
here on the think marketing youtube
channel which i hope you're subscribed
plus our tuesday podcast that's coming
out
and i'm excited to uh to help in any way
i can
with what you're
struggling with or doing on youtube
smash like shout out to the third cup of
coffee from d
this is just my second cup of coffee
however my these cups of coffee
it's pretty big though it's it's it
might be
two or three worth uh size there
malacare says what does a typical video
mean
so what happens with youtube analytics
is
youtube is always judging your videos by
just your typical video performance
this is powerful because it means you
don't have to compare yourself to
anybody else
you get to compare yourself to who you
were yesterday
your goal is to to just beat your past
best and we always encourage you try to
get one percent better with every upload
so one of the best ways to see this is
right here
we uploaded a new video today on how to
create your youtube channel
like actually how to set up a youtube
channel and see it says
that it actually compares your videos to
your last 10 uploads
and so this would be what your typical
is um
but actually typical goes bigger than
this so this is again all it's doing is
just judging it by your last 10 to kind
of let you know was this topic good was
it bad
if you're going to the actual video
itself typical is this gray line right
it's just on average across think media
as many videos as they're evaluating
in my opinion i think it's all of them
so they're saying
think media listen by hour 16
once a video has been out your videos
are typically at 5400 views
on the low end and on the high end
they're at 8 700 views that's your
typical video performance
the blue line is how this one video is
performing and that's why
the youtube analytics will tell you
these things like you're looking good
this video is similar to what you
usually get so you're like alright cool
and and that's the dream just keep
putting out solid videos
a if you're below it if this little blue
line is below the gray you go okay what
can i learn from that maybe i shouldn't
talk about that topic anymore
and if the blue line is far and above
see this one is on track to kind of
follow this
typical video trajectory but what we can
do
is we can go into a video like like one
of these ones where
that omar did with the etis on the
thumbnail look at that
so your typical is this tiny little gray
line down here
and this one shot up bang and then it
kept going
boom
we're still going into space and this is
kind of why like
in our video racket academy program we
have the rocket r your ultimate goal is
to rocket your video's performance and
have it literally be
like a space spacex launch
into orbit uh and
a lot of that actually has mostly to do
with how
good your content is how good your
click-through rate is um
you know we compared this to that last
one this this guy
with his mini it's gotten five million
impressions and yet it's holding a
click-through rate of around five
percent or 5.1
so that's what your typical video
performance is that's a really good
question
and uh thanks for the question dare
shift what kind of videos
are better for marketing products that
will help get past
the algorithm uh i think that's just
about learning
uh any video is fine
but it's making great videos that really
add value so
it's not about making videos that feel
like a commercial or making videos that
are just overly promotional i think dare
shift the goal is to teach
if you can teach and explain and that
whenever somebody watches one of your
videos they learn something
if you're going to market a product
still ask yourself how can the audience
feel like i learned something whether i
buy
the product or not so sometimes product
reviews are probably the best way to
market a product or a versus video
is the best way to maybe talk about two
products and compare one to the other
and have links to those so people could
purchase them but if
you can build a reputation or make it
so that people actually learn something
in your videos while you're talking so
they're not just being
uh pushed you know a product is just
being pushed but they're actually like
huh i mean i'm gonna buy the product but
now i know
in our case on think media you watch
maybe one of omar's videos
and you learn seven new things about
cameras you never knew before even
though you're not planning on buying a
new one
then people want to watch anyways and if
they're
in a moment where they're like i'm ready
to upgrade my camera then there even
trust has been built like
yeah i mean i see that you know your
stuff and um i would love to
uh based off of the relationship i've
built or how
or built with you or how clear this
video was
i'd love to potentially invest in a
product uh peter says i did a niche
pivot should i unless poor performing
videos in the old niche
really poor performing videos aren't the
problem peter the real problem
is videos that are performing well that
are not attracting the right audience
for you now so a lot of times somebody
will start a barbecue channel and then
pivot to creating jeep and off-roading
content
but have these two old barbecue videos
that just blow up and get like thousands
of views every month
so every time someone clicks subscribe
for barbecue content but you no longer
upload barbecue content
you know someone clicks subscribe
because you have these two hair tutorial
videos
that are drawing all these subscribers
but you don't even talk about hair
tutorials anymore
they potentially are going to confuse
the youtube algorithm
your goal peter and everybody is
to never upload videos your subscribers
didn't subscribe for
so if you have a video that's actually
attracting
so for example i have all of my old
videos are poor performing like my first
video ever is still up on think media
there's a lot of early videos that are
terrible they show my journey but
they're also not being watched
so here's the action item friends
you want to go into your real-time views
you want to go into your real-time views
and ask yourself this is your real-time
views
are any of these videos off-brand for
you
so if our top video was like how to
grow a better garden and it was getting
a whole bunch of subscribers
then i'd be like shoot all these
subscribers probably expect us to upload
more
gardening tips videos and we don't even
do gardening tips
so you may want to consider unlisting
videos that are attracting the wrong
subscriber to your
channel alright and so we do our best of
course
think media is still somewhat of a
variety channel because whether it's
video editing
or cameras i mean we put it under the
umbrella of
camera accessories tech gear reviews in
terms of laptops microphones etc
really the more niche you can be for the
youtube algorithm the better
because you never want to upload a video
your subscribers did not
subscribe for great question smash like
if you
are fired up today and we're going to
have greg
coming on the show we got greg in the
house man coffee with cannell where are
you watching from
what's your youtube channel about and
how can i help yo what's up sean
i'm watching from new mexico and i just
first want to say
thanks to you and then also vid iq
i've been able to just kind of skyrocket
my channel this
these last two months because of the
tips
so my question is i kind of i guess
twofold
i've been doing youtube shorts and that
has been the biggest generator
of views and subscribers on my channel
but i've been wanting to do
more in-depth breakdowns i have a gaming
channel and i've been just focusing on
one game right now
warzone and there you channel called
it's called maverick gaming but without
the
vowels so mv rck gaming
awesome and so uh
i so do i continue to do youtube shorts
because that's how i'm getting my views
or should i invest
and i've you know been i just barely got
through your guys's
youtube influence challenge which was
amazing and i'm thinking about investing
into some of your guys's programs
so i can maybe promote and get more
views on
uh like longer form videos i don't want
to go too long but just like that you
know five to ten
minute range i know you've been talking
a lot about doing shorter videos this
year
and so i don't want to go too long but i
want to be able to give
in-depth you know tips and guides it's
something that i enjoy doing is kind of
like teaching and coaching
100 so your top three videos yeah are
crushing ten thousand thirty six
thousand sixty five thousand
those are all youtube shorts correct um
have you checked the analytics and seen
if they're also driving subscribers
uh yes um the the the youtube shorts are
the ones that are driving most of the
subscriber base i have
one long form video which has helped me
start getting that affiliate marketing
which you know i've learned from you
guys uh six dollars so far so i'm
crushing it right there yeah here we go
just buy small beginnings 16 turns into
600.
so yeah i'm just trying to figure out
should i continue to do youtube shorts
or should i invest into a program that
will help me get my longer form
videos to start ranking well no it's
it's both
i mean i i would still do youtube shorts
especially with how it's going for you
now
you're tagging them right so there's
like a short shelf is that true
yeah so i have a playlist that i labeled
like watch
while you queue like short videos that
people can watch even while they're like
waiting for the next game to come up
so um super smart you want to use the
hashtag for youtube shorts so that they
go on the shorts
shelf so do i do i have to do that
because i i haven't been doing that but
they've been still going through the
shorts
like when i go when i go to analytics it
shows like ninety percent because of
that it knows them
yeah because i think i think it would be
worth it because it should create
the shelf itself and i know that some
that doesn't show up on some people's
channels
but uh just a thought so it keeps kind
of categorizing there
but i think that with the way your
channel is going i would absolutely do
both
because the way people are engaging with
you um
the content is still on brand in both
cases and i think that those longer
watch times even in terms of like
cpm and rpm uh that's really where
adsense will eventually be i would also
say that generally man you're just
crushing it like
you haven't put out that many videos
total
yeah i mean i mean again a huge thing is
because of those youtube shorts like
those ones is blown up i mean my channel
from it went from like 30 to like
250 in one day you know which was
amazing and then
yeah and obviously and then we'll
eventually get things monetized but
that's yeah that's your hack to get to i
think a thousand subscribers quicker and
way beyond
um and so i mean that's my clearest
answer to the question is it's not
either or
it's both and i think that in your niche
and the way you figured out to do shorts
uh they're doing really well
um and i would also though build your
brand
i would personally want to have a brand
around
longer form content that is sort of that
depth
you know recently we taught on our
youtube strategy workshop that
shorter is better and we weren't even
talking about shorts yeah so this is
like
the short short hack we were talking
about like dating and that as people get
to know you and maybe want to watch your
playthroughs your game
you know game play they'll want to hang
out with you longer awesome
uh but if you want a speed date then do
videos that are like
three four five six seven but you want
this is like hyper speed dating
the 60 second speed dating show is
obviously youtube shorts and potentially
even shorter than that because they
don't even have to be a minute
um you can make youtube shorts off your
phone you're editing them
clearly right because it's gameplay
footage and it would be
probably nearly impossible to do the
ones you're trying to think about in in
the style that youtube
gives you right on your phone but i hope
that's clear enough
i i wouldn't change your strategy i
would personally try to think about how
i could do
one one or two or three smart shorts a
week
um it's great that you're doing the
proper thumbnails so that can hit the
click-through rate on both
desktop and uh you know mobile um and
then
but i would also be sticking with this
show that you plan on doing is that
helpful
yeah for sure just a i guess a quick
fire question
uh just like i guess a one-word answer
like really quick
if i have money to invest but would you
recommend me investing into an editor so
i can pump out more videos quicker
or you know get into one of your guys's
courses you know i've been thinking a
lot about yours as vra that you know i
think i'm sold but i'm just trying to
figure out how to you know
invest my money what is your life
style like how much time a week do you
have to devote to youtube
so i'm a full-time teacher right now but
i
teach remotely so i have a little bit
more you know flexible of a schedule
so you know i can work four to six
sometimes on the you know the
lower end maybe three hours a day for my
you know school job
but then i can invest some but sometimes
it takes up up a lot more working with
students
so it's just kind of very very so how
much hours a week are you putting
towards your youtube channel
um probably 10 15
okay and then how long did it take you
to make um
like your huskers uh video your 10
minute
world record video that was probably the
full
the full week and then i kind of
repurposed it and made it short
so maybe i get two videos out a week if
i do that long form and then a short
firm
form to try to drive people to the long
form yeah i mean
um it's kind of chicken or egg i think
that
the smart thing about video ranking
academy um especially right now is the
lifetime access add-on
it's an investment that you make today
but you're in it
forever you know like for the life of
the program which is
we're all in you know you've met the
team etc
tony is helping a lot of different
gaming channels in a super dip
deep in that niche and so it's that's
like a
obviously if you do something like
vidchops which i would also recommend
um sometimes you may go through an
editor or two and there's
it takes some time to to build it up and
then of course once
the videos are edited and once you've
paid you're not going to get that money
back hopefully the videos continue to
produce
i recommend that but again i we really
view vra as an asset the community
the training the courses the updates for
a really crazy price in light of
everything that you're getting you make
that investment once and it's an
investment that can pay you back
in terms of also finding a couple smart
videos and connecting even more smart
monetization strategies to what you're
doing
um i'm definitely biased and i recognize
that as far as in asking the question
but my move would be
to invest in vra still pump out two
videos a week and make those two videos
better as you're investing in vra
identify and clear a path to the
shortest path to revenue for your
channel
and then get your channel generating 500
a month and immediately reinvest that
potentially into something like vid
chops because for 500
a month you're right around that price
point that would be unlimited edits you
probably don't even need that
because you can do like four videos
potentially outsource that editing
for that longer weekly video for around
300 on vid shops
so and then that becomes like a monthly
thing i think that
you staying in the trenches with your
hands on the lever at this moment
based on your lifestyle and what you
have going is smart
and having a goal of six months
of like really hustling and putting out
content and learning and growing your
channel
stage one and then about six months from
now sort of scale and bolt on
team members via something like vid
shops
and then take it to the moon and i think
with the momentum you have
and with obviously your skill here your
ability to play your understanding so
far
i actually think with the way that
things are going
i think you should be at for sure 10 000
subscribers by the end of this year
i'm leaning more towards like 25 000
things could really get interesting and
you could grow faster than that
um and i also think you could hit that
thousand dollars of
revenue target a month reoccurring
because of just
past videos and smart videos and smart
topics also
uh on a minimum within the next 12
months and that gives you kind of a
really good foundation to play from
and that's how i've lived kind of my
life as well i want everyone to hear
that
i think one of the smartest things you
could do in any business including being
a content creator in the creator economy
is as soon as you start earning money
reinvest it in yourself in your team in
your gear into creating content faster
into a computer because exports take you
an hour now and now they only take 20
minutes
because of a faster processor but
identifying
which lever to pull when that'll get you
to your goals faster
awesome well i just want to say thank
you sean for taking the time answering
my questions
and to all those that are listening um i
wouldn't be where i'm at with these over
100 000 views without sean and his team
and
doing the work and you know listening to
these strategies that they that they
teach so you know you guys are in the
right place so
thanks again everybody thanks sean
you're awesome thank you greg i
appreciate you thanks for coming on
coffee with
kennel show um hey
thanks for being here y'all smash smash
like if you're getting value we're going
to be bringing some people on
um and we're going to answer some more
questions believe in the magic can i use
amazon affiliates to earn
even though i'm at 594 subs or do i need
to wait for a thousand
um let me suggest to you a controversial
opinion
subscribers don't matter
disclaimer of course they matter and
once you have them and you release a
video
you've got a base of people to click on
it when you really start to understand
the youtube algorithm
or really when you identify what really
matters you don't get any adsense from
subscribers
um you can't get anyone to click on an
affiliate link just because
they're subscribed you can only actually
get an action and earn some money or
even make impact
off of a view so
believe in the magic when it comes to
amazon affiliate marketing
here's the target that i want you to
focus on i want you to get
around two to four hundred views per
video when you're hitting an
average of around two to four hundred
views per video or more
um then i would want you to apply for
amazon affiliates with 594 subs i think
you're fine there the question is how
many views are you getting
secondly i would want your channel to be
really clear
in a niche that uh has a clear value
proposition
that when you apply you just have a good
likelihood of getting approved
amazon will know what it is but these
days amazon actually approves channels
quickly
what you need to do is you need to make
a certain number of qualified sales
within a certain window of time
because of that that's why i want you to
be getting two to 400 views per video
so that there's enough momentum that
when you put out videos once you're
approved you have a chance of making
qualified sales and then here's the key
strategy
and then i want you to release at least
three to five videos that are directly
correlated
to earning money what i mean is
to the point of greg he has a video
called
best mouse for call of duty warzone 2021
the smart thing about this video is
if i'm curiou like it's actually related
to purchasing a product i could go here
and actually get
the viper ultimate mouse because if i
watch this video
i probably want to eventually invest in
a mouse
and now this is correlated to a video
that would actually
make a sale here's the opposite is true
if i if i watch how to get 54 kills in
warzone
like i'm not gonna make a purchase after
that if i
if i look at how to get more kills and
avoid damage
using vehicles makes sense so if i'm
watching a product review or a versus
video two products compared
or a top ten list of home office design
ideas like we started
those videos are actually correlated to
shopping and online shopping which is
correlated to
amazon affiliate marketing furthermore
could be software
like click funnels versus kajabi like it
could be something
so once you hit those initial targets
that i just sugges
suggested and actually click funnels and
kajabi has nothing to do with say
getting qualified for amazon affiliates
now you get approved and you want to
make a certain number of sales so you're
going to put out
videos related to people shopping on
amazon
and smart strategic videos with good
thumbnails good titles etc those are
going to drive you the most sales so you
can lock in your amazon affiliate
membership and then
uh you know approval to the amazon
associates program and then scale
from there
would vra help me if i'm not posting my
videos in the english language to be
clear
vra stands for our online course and
group coaching program called video
ranking academy and the answer is yes
video ranking academy is the same in any
language and here's why
the principles are the same good title
good
description good tags keyword research
in a niche
the key is that the program to be clear
is in
english and a lot of people are making
english titles english description
english tags
but it works in any language in fact
there's even more opportunities in other
language
german title german description german
tags german hashtags
speaking german in the video the key is
you to stay aligned
spanish title spanish description
spanish tags people are searching in
spanish
people are clicking and wanting to watch
videos of people speaking spanish if
they speak spanish and want to watch
content in spanish
so works in any language absolutely you
just want to keep it aligned
and just to hit the question of like man
i'm kind of
i speak two languages should i put two
languages on my channel no because you
never want to upload a video your
subscribers never subscribe for and if i
speak spanish but i don't speak english
when you upload the english version i'm
gonna be like what the heck that video
is irrelevant to me i'm not gonna click
on it
keyword is alignment this is why some of
the big channels
actually start to repurpose their
content into multiple languages but they
don't upload the same
video on the same channel my friend judy
it's judy time did a beauty channel in
english
and then did hired someone to dub her
videos to speak over her doing the
makeup tutorials
spanish title spanish description
spanish tags
spanish speaking in the video by being
dubbed to actually speak
into that language and that channel grew
and look could be searched discovered
suggested the whole algorithm
so uh i hope that helps with a little
bit of value as well
in answer to your question we're gonna
have boss katie come on in just a second
but i want to thank
intermittent fasting with ryan for the
super chat one thousand subscribers
only four months in i'm your spirit
animal
i don't know how i feel about that but
thank you for the honor
thanks for all you do the goal is a
hundred thousand by 2022.
ryan i want to challenge you with the
momentum you got going
you might be able to get there before
then but that is an awesome
goal and um thank you so much for
the super chat we got boss katie
on the coffee with kennel show katie
where are you watching what's your
youtube channel about
cool um i live in tempe arizona and my
youtube channel
i started it in 2017 when i actually
moved to arizona from the northwest and
i was just vlogging my adventure
but i've been filming at festivals for
several years so
i used to think my co i just think my
channel was going to be about
like festivals and festival culture and
then over the last few years i just
posted like
very inconsistently very randomly i was
kind of going through a lot of life
stuff
and now this year i'm like more
committed than ever to really growing my
channel
but the it's i still have a lot of
festival content that i want to
incorporate
into the channel but i decided that my
niche
is more so people who want to learn
about like the law of attraction
manifesting your reality the power of
your mindset
um there's a lot of different tools and
techniques around the
um the the teachings i guess of like
manifesting and creating your reality
and my life story is kind of what i'm
using to draw from
as well as like the teachings that i've
studied so what i was thinking i just
released a youtube video yesterday
what's your channel called it's called
boss katie one word
and then i haven't i have a separate
channel called boss katie entertainment
um boss katie's like my online avatar
she's like the social media
you know content creator i'm a
videographer i do a lot of different
types of content
and then my online avatar is building
her
own like my whole theme is like boss
katie is this fifth dimensional being
living in a third dimensional world here
to awaken people to their full potential
so then i have a separate channel that
is a hybrid
of short films mixed with reality tv
so those are like more of structured
episodes
that are going to be released once a
month along with music videos because i
i live with someone who does um like
conscious
uh rapping and you could her music video
is up there
so that's eventually the entertainment
channel
i wanted to grow into a reality tv show
and i've had dreams of it being picked
up on netflix or like a huge
um network eventually and then i want to
keep
boss katie like my personal channel like
my character
on the reality show is still a youtuber
does that make sense yeah 100 so a
couple thoughts
um one just to encourage you and
everyone else
watching i love that you've got
a vision for the two different youtube
channels but i actually want to
challenge you
to potentially put one on hold and
really focus on one channel
yeah it's hard to it's hard to build two
things at once it's hard to build one
thing
you know and sometimes it can divide
your focus and it's helpful
because if you could get say boss katie
more influential you can then use that
influence to actually grow a second
channel faster
if you try and chase two rabbits at once
it's exhausting you may
either you may catch neither or you have
to run out for one barely get it you're
running after the other one it's super
exhausting so you kind of build that
momentum you want to catch the rabbit
tame it train it get it working for you
get the algorithm growing
without your efforts and then
potentially focus on the other one what
do you think about that
yeah so i've thought about that for sure
and maybe
one thing i was kind of thinking about
doing is like over the course of the
next year
because the entertainment channel is
more like like i really
storyboard that and i do the whole
process of like creating
a short film essentially and then the
music videos that i'm working with other
influencers in this city on um
i was thinking about you know
potentially making it the whole series
this year
and not releasing it until all the
episodes are done
for a whole season you know and then i
could like launch them
once a week for 12 weeks and potentially
build more momentum that way um
so what's your end goal like what are
you
trying to kind of uh put your creative
work into the world
impact people while you also do
something to pay the bills during the
day
are you trying to go full time with this
and what does your ideal
end result look like so i
definitely want to be a full-time
youtuber um that's like my career
and career goals because i know that
doing that is gonna can really take me
places as far as being an influencer
and i do um
so basically like for the past few years
i've really been seeing this vision of
the universe is going to bring me
opportunities the more i speak them into
existence
so my channel is like i'm using the
storyline of my life
and i'm like like weekly vlogs to show
what i'm manifesting as i'm manifesting
it
and i have like huge outlandish dreams
that are like
you know if people can see how i started
like homeless or
in my mom's basement or like you know
i've been through
crazy stuff in my life and now i'm like
here in this little house and then you
know i want to upgrade to a nicer house
and then i want to upgrade to a huge
mansion of influencers that are creating
conscious music and media and it's not
something that exists in our world yet
so it's kind of like i want to create
a new entertainment industry like take
hollywood and bring it to phoenix
but create it but make it more of a
conscious
community um so i have really big dreams
within my community here and then within
like the festival industry
and just bringing more mainstream
purpose-driven media
to that culture and to that industry and
to try to integrate
society and that like you know that like
plural energy
or like festival culture integrating it
more into society
by bringing more mainstream media to
those little pockets of the world
big vision so how can i help the most
what's the question now that i kind of
understand what's going on in your world
um so i was thinking
about structuring my youtube channel in
a way that's like
two videos per week and doing a vlog
and then like taking the kind of like
the theme
of the week and creating an
informational video
that's more like a lesson so it's kind
of integrating entertainment
with information and i don't
i don't know if they're like i don't
really know of a lot of youtube channels
that
do that and so i'm kind of curious like
if my channel should be
about like like
you know like do you think it will work
out if it's like yeah i got you
i mean here's what i would do um a lot
of youtube channels do that
so there's two there's only two rolling
niches there's either like macro niches
there's either
entertainment or there's education um
and of course education is more how-to
uh of course cooking gardening
homeschool
a million things camera tutorials even
how to
uh upgrade your material materia in
final fantasy vii how to get a second
heart in cyberpunk 2077. like a lot of
just how to
practical search based we really
encourage people to go that direction
entertainment mr beast uh vloggers
in a lot of cases unless the vlogger is
kind of
a hybrid and there's tons of people
doing the hybrid it's called edutainment
a lot of science channels they make
science entertaining
uh a lot of people hopefully if you're
doing how-to in entertainment
you're also or education i should say
you're as entertaining as possible
during it if you can bring in
it makes me think of like who's your
favorite high school teacher middle
school teacher elementary teacher
and there's the teachers that just
taught you the information that were
really dry and then there's the teachers
that made it fun and like
kind of like brought their personality
and had jokes during it well you were
still learning but they made learning
fun
i think that if i'm you just from one
point of view perspective i think that
the most practical way to reach your
goal of being a full-time youtuber
is to focus much more
on education and
to take the shortest path to revenue
so that you could fund these big dreams
about
doing the shortest path to revenue is
you have money for the mission for the
things you want to do in the future you
know for me
i want to write books i want to employ
more people i want to launch
other youtube channels i want to make
amazon
uh prime and netflix documentaries that
i can self-fund
that i don't even necessarily make but
my team however you got to be practical
about
making money today as well as serving
people and what and so
if i was you i would be making videos
that are like
top five festival secrets top 10
festival secrets
you know 15 ways to get the most out of
burning man
and what i would do is you what you
what you can do is you can still vlog
but it actually changes the point of
view of the vlog people think it's like
two separate things you can educate in a
vlog style
you can integrate entertainment and
lifestyle
in someone learning something in fact
some of the most engaging learning
content furthermore um if we were to
look at you know like how to manifest
in your life when you start using titles
like this
they start being the very specific type
of video
and so for exam manifesting meadow i
would be success leaves clues
this she only has 5 000 subscribers she
has 125 000 views on this video
yeah and and so when you're making
content like that you know that it's
proven you know people are actually
looking for it
but here's the deal you don't have to
stand in front of a white wall and
deliver that information
you could deliver that information
creatively you could stretch yourself as
a filmmaker as a creator
um and you could do it in beautiful
locations
you could be moving around as you do it
you could you could
read it in a into you could write a
script you could deliver the information
into a usb mic
and put beautiful b-roll to it uh we
sometimes can get
find ourselves in a box when it comes to
creating youtube content realizing that
actually we always step up to
the new video that we're about to create
with a blank canvas
and we could actually reach our end goal
and a lot of sometimes
even people think that the education
side is so like
search based content hi here is point
one point two point i mean that's kind
of what i do like i mean
more or less i deliver a lot of things
like that maybe but like
that is just the framework you can layer
on top b-roll
creativity you could bring in art music
all kinds of things
however i do encourage you to keep it
simple
and think about that shortest path to
get to
the first reasonable or and i don't want
you know for you just dreaming so big
you probably hate the war reasonable
but bad first uh that first practical
benchmark
if you're gonna climb everest there's a
few base camps to go to along the way
you don't just shoot to the top it would
also kill you if you did because your
lungs couldn't handle it and you didn't
acclimate
to the air and the uh the ability to
breathe at that level so
i would think that's why i say one
channel because that's the shortest path
to getting some momentum going clear
videos
the the general vlogs i just always ask
what value does the vlog
actually deliver and it's how fast you
want to go
because your willingness to
do of course there's different
approaches so it's one man's opinion but
your willingness to do i think smart and
practical strategies can actually
potentially get you to a place of
influence faster
that even opens the door for you to be
even a little bit more yourself
not that you want to be yourself but
more like vlogging and i'll land the
plane by doing this
you know again as we talk about like how
to manifest things in your life 125
000 views in that example my friend it's
judy time
did a makeup at beauty channel hair
tutorials makeup tutorials
she grew it to hundreds about 500 000
subscribers
and then her and her husband co-author
of youtube secrets benji travis started
a vlog channel
and they started having kids and people
started being interesting interested
why she started practically
in education and then
she built influence and because people
then became
interested in their life
wait what's the behind the scenes who's
the person behind
the makeup tutorial really and and they
started being interested
and there was enough of a core audience
to launch a vlog
okay my opinion that that is that is the
more practical path and when you can see
i love that you can see a big vision
of step 84 in terms of like
tempe phoenix is going to be this
hollywood mech like let's go
but then you take it all the way back to
what's like the shortest path's revenue
to get established to maybe start
investing in some of these other
creators level up my gear
level up my speed and knowing which step
to make
at which stage you are in youtube i
think is is pretty practical so i hope
that helps
yeah but i would think about things in
that way by probably focusing on one
channel
focusing much more on practical content
not letting that limit your creativity
because there's no reason
99 of people are gonna go to a festival
and just kind of like vlog randomly and
title like some of your videos which are
like
um we will talk with katie which is much
more about like people
just kind of wanting to hear from you as
opposed to
go to the festival with the idea of like
seven
weird things you didn't know about where
to get water
shortcuts to a place and then what ends
up happening is you tap
into all the other 100 000 people that
look for information around that
festival and people are like oh katie
she's so dope
wow like oh i don't know and now they're
discovering your channel because you
didn't really make content through the
lens
of just northern light 17 with boss
katie that doesn't even
that's just like a documentation of what
you're doing that's fine
but if you actually went to northern
lights and even if you went
ten highlights seven highlights of
northern lights
and let people see a recap then
everybody was a part of that or
didn't get to go will watch your video
and at the end you're like hey i'm katie
and by the way
if you want to like subscribe this is
the kind of content i do every weekly
then you start building up your audience
because of really taking like
kind of a flipped approach to the
content you have been creating on this
channel does that make sense
yeah it does totally
katie thank you i appreciate you thanks
so much for uh by the way thanks for
making a video
i saw on your thing about think media
yeah i did do that i'm in full scale
uh full sail university also so i took a
little bit of break from school the last
two months but i'm about to start back
up this coming month
but um yeah i did a video
on your channel and um it was fun i
bought my camera because of your channel
thank you yeah hey i appreciate you that
is super
kind of you yeah and uh grateful for the
shout and super grateful that you'd come
on coffee with candle and i hope that
this uh
these tips were valuable today yeah i'm
doing the vra too
so i've been watching um the videos on
the strategy and tagging and everything
and um yeah i'm super grateful also
thank you
you're you're welcome did you watch that
new year's workshop that we did
which one the one that we just did with
the 10 strategies for 2021
uh i don't know you may you may not have
seen you may not even know that we
we added that so you have complete
access to that as a vra member
and i you probably you i know you're
probably pumped you want to go create
videos
absolutely but maybe over the next
couple weeks or whatever it's four hours
of brand new content that we just
recorded
and it is my exact 10 step or 10
strategy playbook
uh as well as tony and heather for the
2021 year so
that's just in your members area so
check that out okay yeah i definitely
will thank you so much
you got it katie appreciate you take
care yeah you too
coffee with kennel smash the like button
if you're sipping coffee or water or tea
or
monster or rock star or kombucha
or wine let me know what you're drinking
drop in the comments and we're gonna
land the plane on a couple questions and
i think another person coming on camera
i'm taking a sip of the atomic coffee
ethiopia did an aeropress
and um it's delicious a little cold but
really good coffee
has different flavor profiles that come
out of it
as the temperature changes um you know i
don't mean to call her out but
there's two groups of people at think
media there's people who
respect coffee and there's people who
don't respect coffee
omar is a 10 out of 10. he's a super
saiyan if you were raiding him by dragon
ball z like super saiyan level five does
it go that high
i am a few steps maybe a lot of steps
behind him but i'm
really into like hipster coffee shops so
i buy
really niche specialty coffee i've got a
fellow
grinder so there's no static in my grind
it's a burr grinder and i grind my beans
to a specific setting i use aeropress i
use filtered
alkaline like certain water
i i'm not gonna use tap water for my
coffee are you kidding like i
buy water jugs when i make coffee on the
road i
bring my aeropress with me when we
travel
um because i'm gonna make coffee even in
our hotel room
better than probably any local local
coffee shops if there aren't many around
and i just don't want to get into a hard
place where
you know i'm stuck without good coffee
so that's the level i'm at
can you imagine omar's even crazier than
that on the other side of the
spectrum and i don't mean to call her
out publicly
so i'm not going to tell you what her
name is heather torres
she's she's a curry girl keurig
and uh you know it's not that i'm
speaking down to that i'm just putting
it down but i'm just are you
are you a a keurig person where are you
on this on the scale coffee with kennel
family this is the coffee with candle
show i've never really talked about
coffee
are you a keurig
and and do you even care about what
brand of keurigs you get
i mean you gotta do a couple of things
number one environmental impact have we
talked about that melissa caputo like
come on like
where those keurigs go after use them
number two there's no way those beans
are fresh not only are they pre-ground
they're in a plastic container for four
and a half years before they ever reach
your house
if the beans aren't ground right before
you brew your coffee you're not serious
you're not a real coffee drinker come on
are you mr strongbro said disappointed
in heather i'm not trying to throw her
under a bus
okay i just did and i'm backing the tire
back and forth over
her right now we got french press people
in the place i feel you
um french press is amazing there we go
there it is andrew french press i tend
to go with folgers oh
just reach back here andrew pull the
knife out of my back
folgers eventually get the burr grinder
though
um evan okay heather just controlled
that on the back end too
of course she's gonna come in and try to
uh
evan i love you bro miss heather so
amazing a time management she uses the
keurig because it's faster i respect
that
and all at the end of the day you do you
boo
you got to do your thing coffee is just
such
a gift from god
keurig's from the devil but coffee the
beans
the fruit did you know it's a fruit
right the the cherry the coffee cherry
so many great coffee shops out there and
when you can go to places like vesta
coffee here
mothership coffee in las vegas
intelligentsia
all right point i think has been made
we're going to answer some questions
still that was a major detour um
and keurig is of
uh nespresso if i got to go with pods i
do like going with nespresso i have to
say that
uh juanita's creative corner i've got
the keurig and my parents have a keurig
it's actually it could be pretty good
hopefully you can get as as fresh
there you go there's the conscious
productivity mary
kearig with the reusable pod amazing
meanwhile diet mountain dew i mean you
got to do you you're like look
i don't do you not even drink coffee i
always do i say is today a coffee day on
my instagram stories
20 of people say no and then i always
get 20 dms that go
when is it not they're like mad they go
like what do you mean it's today obvious
like a rhetorical question like every
day is a coffee day
all right coffee with kennel detour of
uh
actual coffee and what is your coffee
order the second thing i'm offended by
as we land the plane on this i'll answer
your question we'll bring somebody else
on
if you say you love coffee but you get a
venti
peppermint mocha
with extra whipped cream and only one
shot of coffee
you don't drink coffee like i i mean i
don't
i mean to be abrasive if you get
that pink unicorn drink at starbucks
looks delicious
but you're not a coffee drinker people
are like hey you want to go get some
coffee let's go to starbucks
should we grab should we jump in the car
grab a starbucks yeah let's go get some
coffee
yeah i'll take a um i'll take a green
tea lemonade this is
you're going to get you can't get a
green tea lemonade if you're on your way
to get coffee
yeah i'll take the unicorn pink drink
yeah i'll get a mocha frappuccino
no a chino
i'm a little saucy today about it tell
me your coffee order in the comments
drop it down there here's here's
julian's the real deal
as we land the plane freaking v60
costa rica has some incredible blends
vestas costa rica here in vegas by the
way i drink my coffee black
if you add cream to your coffee oh we're
about to get controversial
this is when the civil war started think
media think marketing
split everyone got offended cancel
culture
canceled think media cancel think
marketing cancel the coffee order
sean offended me listen dude if you're
brewing coffee in a v60
you're doing some pour overs you're
you're you're doing your beans if you
add cream to your coffee
i mean you're not really appreciating
the coffee you know like
like i don't know cream and sugar it's
fine
you do you but but the point of the
coffee is the notes and the flavor and
the acidity
and the the profile and every little
detail and nuance that comes through
and it is my opinion and i'm on a
mission to help 10 000 people
start appreciating just kidding but uh
i'm i actually interestingly enough i
think for a lot of us
we've maybe never really had a good cup
of coffee but i could just be crazy
because here's what my wife sonia says
she likes a verismo which is kind of
like a keurig she's like your coffee's
gross that's what she tells me
she's like it's weird it's like fruity
i'm like yeah your coffee is bitter and
old
you know how i talk to my wife okay so
um here we go we're getting into
start a hip hop coffee channel this is
where the inspiration happens
um we're gonna get into the next uh
question here we're gonna bring drew on
the show
and drew it's good to see you man where
what is your channel
uh it is from and how can i help yes
north carolina
raleigh area uh it's called swag talk
a big fan bra member here so definitely
got all that on lockdown i didn't know
about
yeah swag talks design yep i went to
raleigh once
um i ate i ate hush puppies and i drank
the sweet tea okay is that a thing that
happens in raleigh right
i mean i guess like a lot of deep fried
things maybe and sweet tea
because i went and i was doing this
church communications things for a
church and they took me to this place
and there was hush puppies and deep
fried everything and they said we drink
the sweet tea and they called it the
sweet tea
and and i was like this is so good and
then i drank like 10 glasses and got
super sick because there was so much
sugar in it
yeah that's that's not how you all do it
over there i guess
yeah it is very common i don't know
about the the hush puppies are not
everywhere the further south you go
yeah it's you can get it as a side with
anything you might be we were we were
deep
i mean wherever we were all right so uh
i'm on the channel
well how can i help so my question
and um i want to round it i'll start
with a
just an overarching question then i'm
around it in the clubhouse because i saw
you on clubhouse the other day so i have
a question about that um so i know right
edgy topic
so i am more in the education niche i
know you just mentioned kind of
education versus
entertainment um and i'm in a part
a couple of different groups so when i
drop
a video in a group it does fantastically
subs go up i mean if you look at the
stats in the the channel everything's up
like the 999 percent
which is dope um just crossed 250 doing
a giveaway for that so that's really
cool just small
me and a couple friends started youtube
around the same time started in march
last year
um but if i don't drop one
because it's not relevant like so if
it's a lettering facebook group
i might drop a lettering youtube link in
there and it'll do great
but if i do something on books for
example i'm not going to try
drop top three books in the facebook
channel because it doesn't relate to
them
and then this it sits at like 60 views
or 50 views
so i think it's a pretty common problem
but i'm not sure if like do i need to go
out and just
start engaging with a ton more like
accounts like i'm trying to figure out
is my seo wrong is my tags wrong i have
the second level of
what is it vid iq got that integrated so
it's showing me all those stats
um but it's really like the rise and
shine videos are coming from when i
share
in the in the group so like traffic's
coming straight up from facebook and
instagram and then a little bit from
email marketing starting that a little
bit
yeah yeah yeah all right well a couple
things uh
you know also in vra you know that we
have the uh
the rocket r and um and that would be
sharing it in a facebook group super
smart because in a way traffic is
traffic
you want to get the views and then you
want to convert over time
those viewers into subscribers but an
important thing to know
is the best way to grow a youtube
channel
is youtube itself infinitely better than
social media unless you have insane
amounts of influence on social media or
you get lucky with like the press or
someone shouting you out or tweeting you
which won't happen to most of us right
so to get real leverage on your youtube
channel
i would ask i'd ask like just a couple
questions
number one which topic
should i talk about that if i could rank
and be in suggested videos for this
topic could rapidly grow my channel
secondly hopefully that topic is also on
brand or it needs to be it should also
be on brand to attract
my ideal subscriber
um and then and then i would make those
videos
more often and let them do the work for
me immediately i actually think
um this is kind of a this is a cool hack
that you'll see right here uh
we did a video because i think you
should do a free fonts video
and you gotta figure out of course um
you know rights things like giveaway
whatever
but watch this think media
sound effects y'all y'all in the coffee
with kennel show about to get a secret
that we haven't really shared that's
kind of hidden in plain sight but notice
this
free sound effects pack youtubers use
it's royalty free
and it's just actually a collection of
sound effects a lot of people will just
download the youtube video i've used
that for sure
and um and then additionally though
we actually set it up so that you can
download the
sound effects and we built an email list
30 000 people or something like that so
far have opted in so that's
a whole another crazy so and then the
video ranks
because it's the desire of a particular
audience now this might attract a
surface level
uh person but that video what could
potentially i mean the sound effects one
has
almost 400 000 views so i'm asking
myself
in your niche of design what are the top
videos you know and if we were to look
at like free fonts this is just one idea
you know free fonts uh for 2020 here's
you know 2021's interesting it's 196
000 views so you want to be making
videos
about like those high volume type search
topics
um that are relevant for your audience i
think it's also interesting
you can expect tutorials for adobe
programs okay
yeah a little like procreate icons and
then like
uh there's a lightroom one xd
photography
clues like your top video has 1200 views
and it's on procreate like if you did
a 10 part procreate series that thing's
gonna
grow like a fine wine getting better
with age
um you know if you again again did
the other one you're saying adobe
program so illustrator or whatever else
i mean i think that's actually where i'd
see the channel steering
then of course some of the things you're
learning inside of our you know
membership area and whatnot i think
building an email list
thinking about ways to monetize thinking
about even eventually like probably in
your case definitely like some
a digital product something to sell like
on the other side
of putting out the right videos working
hard but like building up a library of
the right topics and the right type of
content dude it's game over for you
clearly your skill is off the chart i
mean i love the stuff love the vibe love
what you're able to pull off
so like that's also a good foundational
key people are gonna want to get the
results
that you're able to get you go if you go
if you went all in on like procreate
photoshop you know other adobe programs
free fonts
and then the biggest thing i would ask
is the last piece of homework
would say who are your top
10 to 20
kind of ideal competitors or and maybe
they're not perfectly ideal but what can
you learn
from the top 10 to 20 channels that you
maybe would aspire to be
be like i saw one that was 500 000
subscribers what can you learn from them
and what are their top videos let's just
do it really quick
so satori graphics so i would imagine
your goal would be to have a half a
million subscribers eventually
right and so looking at them
when i think and yeah five chrome
extensions these success leaves clues
the
types of videos i can already tell your
ability to create video
and your ability to know your craft is
unstoppable
so it's actually this is hopefully a
hope a really encouraging call because
bro
you have unlimited success on just the
other side of execution
wow thank you and so if we go to most
popular
and we think about five golden rules of
minimal graphic design so some rules
uh three illustrator clipping mask uses
that you need to know
even their title title structure
so they've got some interesting topics
so again what can you learn from these
this guy's top videos
with fit iq if you go to this trending
tab
this is even more important than the
popular videos
because this tells you which videos are
getting view velocity
and i'm not so much interested in 15
hours or three days ago because new
videos of course will get view velocity
by the way this guy's doing logo design
so i'm just thinking of the business
model i'm sure he's crushed like
so you start thinking about what do you
want your business model to be but i'm
actually most interested two months ago
kind of
i'm really interested in two years ago
six golden rules of layout design you
must obey
38 views an hour wow so like the
older video three years adobe indesign
tutorial booklet layout
for print in design tutorial so i like
to look at the
here's the key with vid iq installed and
if you're new coffee with channel and
don't have it iq
you can check out vidiq.com forward
slash think for a 30 day trial
this trending tab i think comes with the
free version but you only see like the
first couple videos so you can study
in depth videos that are getting vph
views per hour that means they're
getting present velocity
and what opportunity that gives you is
that
you actually want to make potentially a
similar
video so i would not hesitate to make a
video called three
illustrator clipping masks uses you need
to know
dude i'm gonna make five five
illustrator you like like it's
it becomes kind of success leaves clues
you make your own version of the video
but because it's getting 30 views an
hour what that tells you is even kind of
more than search volume it tells you
that on youtube
there's present like 30 humans obviously
at least
are consuming that that's a ton that
type of content around the world
you're going to add a video with the
goal of getting in suggested videos
around the intent of humans on certain
topics
so that if they see three they're like
those are dope and then your video gets
suggested
essentially next to satori's they're
like he's got five
and if you do different ones or if you
do like one
cool illustrator clipping mask use you
need to know
like new for 2021 because illustrator
always drops new you know
drops new features then it's like that
video is this three-year-old video
that's getting 30 views an hour
you drop a new one and boom you're
suggested
and and on the other side of any of
these strategies i'm suggest
suggesting your channel's nothing but
net does it make sense your channel is
you know
yeah nothing but growth right yeah no
that makes sense
where yeah i feel like where i was
getting more scared is like well that
video exists
right so like satori obviously a
powerhouse pixen perfect
powerhouse the future a powerhouse you
know what i'm saying so like
it comes up and people are are clicking
on that
and again not saying that i can't do
that and you're you're right on the
money like they update all the time so
i've already got like
radial two tools shortcut commands like
stuff that they update all the time
stuff that can be
evergreen i'm trying to find like the
evergreen stuff so like
stuff like i just did like eight brush
pack
that that's like very specific but like
that's not
so much evergreen you know so i think
yeah i did i didn't know that using the
trending tab
on us on when you're on someone's
specific channel did that
i don't know how i missed that but i
must have not got that
that far in the ranking academy if i
didn't pick that one up but
that's a super dope little hack and two
things
so i want to hit because i think this
will add value to everybody here
the the one mindset of other people are
doing it
um you got to just do it as well and
don't even really in fact if other
people are doing it we just had brendan
kane
author of hookpoint on our think
marketing podcast and he said i love
saturated markets
because it proves that there's interest
so there's two benefits of a saturated
market one is just the long tail and the
long tail is yeah other people are doing
it so satori is getting 300 views an
hour
but listen the opportunity for you to
get three views an hour
especially when you're just starting and
like under a thousand subscribers
is massive it's called the long tail
yeah so i was just looking up like the
canon m50 we've made like 30 videos
we got peter we got kinotica we got tech
through the lens
we got tech gear talk we got us we got
the camera store tv we got chris winter
yeah we us again we got tyler we got
catherine manning
we got tom rich like and
and then we got a and a lot of these
have
ninety two thousand three hundred six
thousand but do you know how many videos
have
50 88 because they're on the climb
don't be afraid if other people are
doing i want everybody to hear that like
literally don't be afraid
of other people are doing it just jump
in
you never know which video is going to
break out now of course the nuances of
different is better than better
try to find your unique angle but one of
the biggest aspects of your
unique angle is you nobody else
is like you you got to be you times two
amplify your personality put your
personality into the product review put
your personality into the tutorial
and guess what some people aren't going
to like you some people will be like i
don't want to listen to
this weird dude with the weird part talk
about this camera i want to listen to
kathryn manning the female talk about
this camera i don't
i don't like catherine manning because i
don't like white people
i want to listen to somebody ethnic talk
about this camera that's how the world
works
like and so just be you times too you
put yourself
out there get on camera uh and do your
version of it
try to uh you know bring unique angle
but even catch
that long tail the second mindset i want
to hit too
is in the midst of yes you want to go
for evergreen topics but when you're in
the early stages of growing your channel
you want to be as scrappy as possible
and jump on
any opportunity that's strategic as
quick as possible so that you can build
up that base of subscribers
it's not either or it's both and you
want to build up those long tail
videos and and the thing is
um a lot of those will still be
evergreen i mean even if it is just like
a new update to illustrator or something
yeah like that's gonna be watched in my
opinion if evergreen is at least a year
or like even six months but like if it's
a year year and a half two years like
it could be a lot more evergreen than
you think um and
early on you don't want to get overly
romantic about that and here's the
opportunity drew
and coffee with candle community one of
the things that you have the advantage
of
if you're a small youtuber a new
youtuber a new creator
is speed of implementation
and you might have kids work
life and you might have limited hours
but also you potentially have
flexibility this is actually kind of an
interesting
way to look at it yes think media we
could do what we want
like i could wake up and hustle and have
speed of implementation today
but on the flip side we are actually so
far ahead now because we're a 13-person
team yeah that we have videos we shot
like a while ago we're still shooting
them
meaning what like a new thing new tech
comes out
a new update happens on photoshop
something new happens
and even just for like the health of our
team culture i'm not like
frick stay up all night like i mean i
want people to they have to like clock
out at like the right time and stuff and
like sometimes we push and we definitely
have a hustle spirit and we work really
freaking hard
but it's a little bit of a different a
season i'm trying to encourage you
be scrappy when you're starting and it
reminds me of back when
i started uh when we were starting video
influencers
and there was this app that came out
called meerkat
live streaming app and then
there it was announced that an app was
coming out called periscope
direct competitor so everyone's jumping
on meerkat i was a little bit late to
meerkat i know you want to talk about
clubhouse
and then i uh and so i i
but i saw periscope and i remember at
the time i was working at a church
and i was really working monday tuesday
wednesday thursday friday was my day off
and then saturday evening i had to get
ready for sunday so my day off was
friday
and half a day saturday and thursday
night i
heard that periscope was being announced
and boom
speed of implementation i was in a hard
season but i was like dude i'm going to
freaking grind
i'm going to hustle so i started to
research everything that was out there
and you've heard us teach the version
strategy periscope
versus yeah beer cat
and i i researched everything that was
out there i hustled
this is my apartment in irvine
california
and i made a video i i planned it out on
friday
shot it on friday edited it on friday
i'm doing every i'm a solo crater like
i was actually doing the channel with
benji but i was at this point doing all
of the editing
right all the heavy lifting stuff you
get it and so
uh and then i release it saturday
morning
and this video was
2015 24 000 views
and here's a good point dude it's not
meerkat like doesn't even exist anymore
so
nothing's ever gonna be like necessarily
it might be but it's not gonna be like
evergreen forever
and eventually once you have authority
on your channel you may be able to rank
for like illustrator tutorial like a
two-word title
like and like maybe something that's
like so holy grail that it just
but by making smart moves like this
this i believe boosted us we're at like
a couple hundred subscribers it gained
like over a thousand subscribers from
one video
jumped on the right topic at the right
time speed of implementation
i'm pulling screenshots i'm i'm breaking
down details
this is another key i didn't like rush
it out but i rushed
it out i was like i saw the end from the
beginning i was like i want to rank this
video
um i want to be the dominant video on
this topic
and so the takeaway coffee with kennel
fam and drew
is that there might be some times where
you see the opportunity you have the
ability
to as soon as illustrator releases
something go i'm going to hustle on that
because satori is probably a little bit
comfortable he's also
it might not be comfort it's also just
like he's stable so he's at a place
where he's like dude i got so much
passive use coming in i mean cool like i
could jump on that video
but like i don't necessarily need to
here's my content calendar
where hear me as youtube channels grow
and teams grow
they become like ocean liners they can't
turn
as fast when you're a small youtuber
you're like a speedboat
you're just like boom i'm going to jump
on that scrappy mentality that you want
to have
when you really want to reach your
youtube goals early on and trigger
growth
yeah and i think that's i think that's
funny you bring up the meerkat because
i'm wondering what happens now with
clubhouse because i think it's a little
bit of a game changer
and i was in some rooms earlier where
they were talking about
trying to intertwine all of this stuff
but youtube still be in the bread and
butter and it's still weird it's they're
still working out the kinks they just
accepted android so now it's like every
room is like 300 400 500 people
um and so i'm i'm wondering i mean i
know if this is a time for this it's not
time for this i'm just wondering like
what does that look like for youtubers
to take advantage of clubhouse or is
that not our thing i mean
it's speaking we should be comfortable
speaking so
yeah let's talk about the good the bad
and the ugly of
clubhouse you know
number one the good i do think it's
gonna be big
number two uh i do think that it's a
unique platform
that is offering a lot of value um
something new to the space it is
different than kind of anything else
number three when you can be an early
adopter there is the potential potential
to
meet people grow an audience make
connections
um number four again if you move fast
you can
the good is you you might be able to
grow an audience
achieve whatever you know thing that
that you want to achieve
uh the bad the bad is
it's pr you have to ask yourself what's
the purpose of being on clubhouse
and am i uh is it
productive for me or is it actually me
kind of procrastinating pretending i'm
being productive
right and so a lot of people you have a
chance to get in these incredible rooms
and listen to incredible people share
incredible information
question do you need more information
right now or do you you need more
implementation i see some people
in rooms learning about youtube when
they should be making youtube videos
i agree exactly i see some people
going from room to room gathering random
information
where listen i believe that
smart leaders they do not put they do
not allow their education to be random
they are intentional about their
education
so before ever going on to
clubhouse you should ask yourself this
question
and really before you do anything is
this the best use of my time right now
right and if there's a reason to do it
if you say i've i put a video out this
week i promoted it
i did i've taken care of my job i just
put my child down to sleep
my wife knows i love her and now i'm
doing my hobby time but we'll do
whatever you want with your hobby time
like it might need to be another
you know but but if you've got a video
to edit
you've got some work to do you also have
intentional structured learning like
maybe even video reagan academy or
something
that is going to get you from point a to
point b to point c to point d
and you're like oh my gosh i can't
believe this person's in clubhouse cool
but it's still just random information
you're actually kind of putting your
future up to randomness and
instead of intentionality right
now i thought sorry go ahead well i was
going to say the other good
is here's an intentional thing it
reminds me of heather
who grew as a communicator on snapchat
because before she started creating
youtubers she wanted to grow her
communication and her camera confidence
in this case would be your speaking
confidence
by every day doing at least stories with
the beginning middle and end on snapchat
if is this the best use of my time i
want to grow in communication in
teaching and so i'm going to start an
intentional clubhouse
room and i don't care if one person's in
there or seven
or three hundred i'm gonna do that so as
to
force myself every monday at ten o'clock
again that's very intentional use from a
speaking standpoint
right furthermore like we're actually
hiring at think media right now and so
we're going to be doing some clubs
where we'll almost kind of be doing like
public interviews of people and right
that's inten but somebody else might be
you also might be on there
looking for a particular connection you
might be looking for a particular collab
it goes back to that's the good you can
meet a lot of people
but then again the bat is i think
treating it to uh
to just being random and the final
worst bad and i want to hear your
feedback too but the final worst bat
is actually not even the clubhouse
problem it's the distraction problem in
general
okay i actually believe probably the
number one enemy
of every single creator and entrepreneur
watching this
is distraction is doing too many things
and splitting their energy and their
focus into too many directions
you think clubhouse is an issue it was
already that
right now my i'm trying to work on my
youtube channel but i feel
pressured to also make tick tocks but
sean tick-tock is so powerful
maybe it is then do it but i'm also
trying to do tick tocks
and i had a couple good weeks of that
but then i got so burnt out that i
haven't actually been back on tick tock
and now
i'm over on clubhouse sitting in rooms
listening to people and then i just
learned that there was a new update to
facebook live so now i'm trying to go
live on facebook and build my facebook
up
meanwhile i heard reels
are you know awesome so now i'm trying
to make reels but what if i repurpose my
tick tock to reels and over to youtube
shorts
maybe you should maybe you shouldn't
because can end up in every direction
and sean i'm trying to create
i think i have two ideas for online
courses so i'm trying to like brainstorm
both
i've got two google docs dude what the
freak you trying to do two online
courses for
get one done well i kind of want to
write like an ebook
but i'm also thinking about starting to
put some of my music on spotify
dude you got so many things going on
you gotta focus follow one course until
successful
if you can figure out and i'm not
suggesting sometimes you gotta play in a
couple things
see which thing is the real discipline
is maybe you're playing in a couple
things you see some life and some
impact and some breakthrough and you
have to be willing to shut things down
and say i'm going to go all in with
blinders on so i can
follow one course until successful what
does successful mean in my opinion
it means momentum it actually means
profit it means money's coming in
it means some scalability to it it means
some automation to it successful means
that there's a level of automation maybe
because of ranked videos maybe because
of
vid chops you have an editor maybe
because
of whatever as opposed to it's kind of
like
juggling and you just are letting balls
drop
and and so i have to throw this one up
and then it hits the ground i throw this
one up and hits the ground and i'm
exhausted and i'm spreading 100
different directions
as opposed to i'm juggling and then i
actually am able to make some money so
i'm able to outsource to did shops
to edit my videos and now they're
juggling so someone else can actually
keep the project in the air and keep it
moving forward
or i'm so good at leveraging the youtube
algorithm
and i crack that code understanding like
video ranking academy
so i got videos working for me so that i
can be like you know it's pretty dope i
got a thousand
real time views uh you know every two
days
i'm gonna reward myself and open up a
new project but too many people open up
too many projects at once
if you try and chase two rabbits you end
up catching neither most creators even
watching this right now
are chasing 10 rabbits yeah wondering
why they're so exhausted burnt out
and then clap clubhouse shiny object
shiny object
you know shows up and like oh dang
that's a good looking rabbit
and now we're following like dude you
got so many unfinished videos on your
hard drive
get back to work and get off clubhouse i
don't care what guru is sharing tips
like do you really need
those what happened is they they went on
there and they saw like
peter mckinnon is under a thousand
followers and they go oh
ooh the the plane is now level again but
it won't be
go back and check it next week he'll
have 10k 20k
i think the problem is you're in these
rooms and there's
very influential people and they're
being real and they're being gritty and
they're they're they're
being honest i think it's amazing
however
they're just they're just talking and
sometimes they're giving you
fantastic information i was in one that
was like instagram
how to instagram and tick tock growth or
whatever just to see on lunch on lunch
break
and it was just like yeah you know
followers are people my dude
i know i got that is that's not like i
didn't need to waste 30 minutes
to hear to hear that yeah i'm not saying
it's bad i'm not shaming them
what it is it's just like i'm trying to
figure out what
what that what is that going to be like
is it
is it for conferences like do we join
like what kind of stuff are they going
to give away to make it worth it
is what i'm trying to figure out what
clubhouse is about
clubhouse right now during a pandemic
is answering a very real problem because
we can't really do conferences
and it is the conference networking
party it's amazing
but here's a great story about that so
here here's the thing that kind of
summarizes what clubhouse is
clubhouse in my opinion is really good
but good is the enemy of the great
and just because something's good
doesn't mean that it's good for you
right now
so i i completely agree i've been in
rooms with some of the most dynamic i'm
like i can't believe these two people
are even talking to each other
and i used to be flying the wall i then
have to ask myself though
like i haven't gone running in the last
week
which is for my health so is it healthy
that i'm able to stay in clubhouse
one day i went running while listening
to club uh to club house oh yeah i was
i was just like i was like hoping i
wasn't invited anything because i was
just consuming
so you could be you could multitask you
could do things and we're not hating on
clubhouse
no no you're talking about like again is
it right for you right now and do you
really need more information right now
or do you need more implementation and
more taking action
and it is so addictive because it's
always there especially if you have
notifications coming on you're like oh
cool
it's it they are really playing on the
fear of missing out
but if you are allowing the fear of
missing out to dictate your
life you are going to miss out on
building the thing that you need to
build and you're going to delay your
destiny
so you have to be really
self-disciplined with it in my opinion
but what's interesting is yes i do think
there's nothing more powerful
than going to our event growth video
live vid summit
vidcon video marketing world these types
of events
and being in a lobby and being in the
serendipity of getting to talk someone
connect with somebody
those moments are magic and clubhouse
creates those moments
and so i encourage people that
especially eventually we'll get back to
live events and we'll see what that does
to clubhouse but i think that clubhouse
is still going to take a life of its own
um however i remember once when
i was hanging out with somebody at this
event called
clamor con in palm springs and we were
talking about
south by southwest and we were talking
about
it was uh about i mean south by
southwest is now like five days ten days
it could be like 15
some people go out and we were talking
about it and he they said have you ever
been there and i was like nah i've never
been there
and at this point too i was going to
like a lot of events a year i'm like i'm
going to ces nab
video you and they're like you should go
sometime but i'll never forget this
friend entrepreneur that i had he goes
or maybe you shouldn't go he goes
because at the end of the day
you got to execute in your business man
you got to build and he's like
you meet a lot of people but do you need
to meet more people right and he's like
and you
you're part of a lot of things but like
do you even need to be a part of more
things
you got to know what season you're in
and you got to make the best decision
for the season you're in right now
and most people should shut the door
shut down clubhouse
shut off as uh you know the queen's
gambit or shut off game of thrones
and sit down and get to freaking work
alternatively
if you're like i think i need to expand
my network i need to meet people i'm in
a learning season
i've been working so hard i should go
relax a little bit i've been working so
hard
i i want to do whatever i want to do
with my time that's
that's i think the message we're getting
across here do you
of course all those events are good but
good is the enemy of the great
and a lot of us can get so lose so much
of our time
to just a bunch of little good things
that we never actually create something
significant
and the biggest thing there i think is
the big mo
as john maxwell says momentum momentum
is
very hard to start it can be hard to
keep going
but there's nothing more powerful than
momentum think media
gets 6 000 real-time views every 60
minutes about a quarter million views
every two days really if we whether we
upload new videos or not
i would argue obviously not to hit that
level
but let me call not you out drew
let me call out coffee with cannell and
say
until you have that going for you
then what the heck are you doing letting
your focus be delayed dude i can do
whatever the frick i want
like and i'm gonna still have money
coming in my family taken care of
my team taken care of furthermore i have
a team
i took me years of focus
to build that so it might be right for
me to be on clubhouse you have to ask
is it right for you to be on clubhouse
that's all i'm saying that's the
framework
is this the best use of my time
so you don't need 6 000 views every 60
minutes
but until you got some real-time views i
saw ben from authentech here
ben has been a full-time youtuber for
five years he's got videos that he made
six months ago earning money for him
today that is
focus follow one course until successful
successful is momentum
income uh you know automation
those types of things when those things
are happening by all means
use your time how you want but time is
the most valuable thing we have we can't
get it back you want to use it smart
invest it smart
and invest your time today and something
that will give you leverage tomorrow
and one of the things that's a problem
with clubhouse as well my friend drew
the ugly side is the
fact that it's ephemeral it disses it
disappears
yeah that's also what makes it cool so
it's also a good
but youtube is the only platform where
your content truly lives forever
because it's owned by google so when you
invest in youtube you invest in the
future
when you invest in clubhouse maybe
you'll meet a relationship
maybe you'll learn something maybe
you'll get an unlock
but that also sounds like you're leaving
your future up to chance and so you're
kind of rolling the dice it's sort of
like gambling or it might just be
dopamine
addiction that's happening as we're just
hoping some fomo moment happens
who knows that's why i like betting on
and banking on
making your next smart video
strategically
because then you can spend as much time
on clubhouse as you want
you can go snowboarding hang out with
your friends go to south by southwest
for 10 days
what is it worth to you to build a
business that has created so much
automation and lifestyle and income
that you actually have truly reached
autonomy financial freedom time freedom
location freedom and
it's very hard to build that but the way
to build that is to invest today
in what is the best use of my time so
drew what do you think those are a few
thoughts on clubhouse
yeah no wow you went off i got it no
that that's great i just
i wanted to know your thoughts like when
i saw the live come up i was like i'm
gonna ask him about clubhouse
because i feel like unless you had some
baller connections
or you're already somebody
i don't know how you're gonna grow i
mean you can get called up
you know and i've been in that little
section where it says like you know
people
that follow or like yeah people that the
speakers follow that little midsection
and then people click on and follow or
whatever but like unless you're
kind of already in the know
i feel like a lot of people are going to
go there trying to grow
stats like instagram or something and
it's just not the same and we'll have to
see we don't really know what the
algorithm looks like or the seo quite
yet so
it's just interesting like you said to
see how it grows but i think
for me it's been a little bit of a
distraction so i'm glad that you talked
about that because
if you would have said to me like here
are the top five ones that we're gonna
schedule and these might be beneficial
for someone that can't do video but they
can listen on their bike or in the car
sweet let me know i'll i'll set it up
and listen to that but
if you just have like seven invites to
like these rooms
that are just talking about like my life
the first two years as freelancer
sure 100 and you know some final
thoughts
is you know i think there is the power
of it's like talk radio
if you're driving that's i've been
listening to some stuff while i'm
driving
and sometimes i might get put up as a
moderator or something and i'm like
shoot my connection's not very good
but that's you're going to consume
either music or talk radio or sirius or
whatever
well it's just putting it in the right
context that's an opportunity
to your point drew we are
starting this friday at
11 a.m pacific time 11 to 12.
we're putting it we're putting a blocker
on it and we're doing a friday show
every single friday heather taurus or me
or both and tony
and other guests and our youtube friends
are going to be on clubhouse so we're
we're using it
and i think that's some good guardrails
we're going to be using it as far as
maybe there'll be some random stuff but
our pillar time
is uh fridays 11 to 12
and we're going to start building up a
meet up and build up a room
and and be there and kind of the way we
run any of our content it'll be focused
it'll be structured it'll be like coffee
with cannell
you know we'll have q a we're actually
going to start off by sharing
like a five to ten minute tip uh and
that's something that people can really
anchor on and build up momentum around
that
that provides value and it'll provide
value for
all kinds of people to maybe come in the
room and you know if you're in there
we like we could add q a you're on stage
it brings awareness to what you're doing
of course there's that thing
and knowing that that goes back to what
heather torres teaches all the time too
about like priorities and scheduling and
that's the that's the danger of
clubhouse
is it's the wild west it's like yeah
it's like i wanted to do the scheduled
thing but what the heck
you know i mean like celebrities are on
there oh you know what i mean like crazy
you're like we're like snoop dogg is
talking to grant carter
i mean you're just like what the heck is
going on and sometimes that maybe calls
you in
and and look i mean we might seem
regimented
in our approach which i think is needed
it's called discipline and it does
lead to uh results when you stay focused
on the flip side i mean whatever like i
think there's a lot of things we could
give our time to and if you're giving
your time to
learning and to connecting and to
exploring um i am actually encouraging
people
that i do think clubhouse is something
you should pay attention to
yeah but i think don't lose sight of
your priorities
and multiple times a day ask this power
question
about everything you do is this the best
use of my time right now
and when that next video and that
research you need to do
on a youtube video and something you
should put out or that new youtube short
you should put out
if that's actually the best use of your
time my mom used to tell
there's something about that ancient
wisdom like pissed
she's like i'm not ancient but my mom
used to say this
all the time and i will never forget it
she told me sean do the hard thing
first right do the hard thing first
and uh heather was asking about my
parenting style because i'm a four month
old now and she said what are you gonna
do with video games i said i'm not sure
yet but she said
did you have limitations on the video
games you played growing up i said no my
parents didn't give me any limitations
on video games
wow they just said do the hard thing
first
and if you've done your chores and we
lived on six acres so i not only
had a push lawnmower for our front yard
i had a riding lawnmower for our bigger
field
and i no joke had a tractor with a mower
deck
for the acreage after i mowed the grass
and did my homework yeah you could do
whatever you want with the rest of your
free time sean
are you doing the hard thing first are
you focusing on the thing that matters
most and i think that even builds more
confidence
it has us so we didn't wake up feeling
like dude i just wasted yesterday i mean
like i learned some stuff but honestly
like i'm not proud because i didn't
really actually accomplish anything
i didn't ship anything i didn't put
anything out there i really just
consumed
and that's a good benchmark too with
clubhouse and any content creators in
general
can i call the content creators out if
you are a content
creator you need to be creating content
not consuming content
only and if you're consuming more
than you create it's probably a good
barometer a good measuring stick
of you're not spending your time wisely
should you be consuming content of
course because you want to learn you
want to level up
but it's not either or it's both and and
i want to challenge you to create more
than you consume
if you've created thank you mom if
you've done the hard thing first
now dude i want to chill on clubhouse
it's super fun i'm hanging with people
we're doing meetups
do whatever the heck you want with your
time yeah
but do the hard thing first create first
consume second
get your work out of the way get
projects done
and close the 48 open loops that you
have and get one thing in the mail
get one ebook on amazon get one digital
product actually created in for sale
get one youtube channel that's at least
uploading a video per week
get one youtube channel that not only is
doing a video per week but a live stream
per week
get one thing that's systematized
automated momentum
and then add-on and simplify before
you complexify and that's potentially
the trouble of clubhouse
is it adds a whole nother thing that
could steal our time
yeah but you're right i think it's
definitely valuable it's gonna be
powerful
um and it can be productive i've had
some productive conversations but yeah
good in the bad and ugly just like you
said
well let's land the plane drew with that
i'm inviting everybody to join us at 11
00
a.m pacific standard time on clubhouse
every friday no joke you can follow me
sean cannell you can see the name right
there and uh
i am on clubhouse that will be a very
focused hour
and we will be sharing very practical
tips that can help you
but i actually will tell you right now
if you go you know what sean
i am actually a little bit on
information overload and i need to get
into execution
mode yeah then do that yeah we'll be
there for you
we'll be there every friday at 11 we're
paying attention to it
and you got to ask yourself as we land
the plane drew
is this the best use of my time this
week is this the best use of my time
today maybe skip one
maybe take a month off from clubhouse
it'll be there when you get back
we uh it's a hard decision as an
entrepreneur and as a creative person
who always wants to do a million things
and launch a million projects
but i'm telling you friends slow and
steady wins the race
never ever rush it's true regan films
hey drew i appreciate you man thanks so
much for coming on
yeah thanks so much hey coffee with
kennel crew
uh i hope you enjoyed that session
we're gonna chop that out into some kind
of a cohesive list
and i'll put my clubhouse thoughts out
on uh
on think media too
because that was a fun conversation
marcus
uh roberto blake calls cub house a time
suck
he's he's right
he's not wrong and i'm not saying
clubhouse is bad
i hope you heard us but it can be of
course anything could be
video games can be a time suck or you
have a gaming channel and it could be
the way you're building your business
matt says eat that frog that's a great
book brian tracy y'all
eat that frog eat the frog in the
morning
first thing which is getting the the
hard thing out of the way
because you don't want to eat a frog but
once you do you feel proud of it brian
tracy what the heck were you talking
about man
the analogy kind of breaks down for me
but it is a powerful powerful book and
principle
um jean i'm currently listening to start
by john a calf
love john love start gene john's coming
on the think marketing podcast he's got
a new book coming out called soundtracks
about overthinking
another plague of the entrepreneur mind
and uh excited for having john on the
think marketing podcast
if you aren't subscribed here on youtube
click subscribe think marketing
if you are a user of spotify
uh google google yeah google play
um apple we also have the audio podcast
every tuesday there for you
i uh will invite you
that if there's one thing you should do
on clubhouse it's beyond our show
that is on fridays at 11am
excited if you've never been there i
don't know if it's fully fully open yet
another great recommendation from jesse
good to see you jesse
do the work by stephen pressfield not
only is that a great book that's a great
book
to read anytime the resistance
is rearing its ugly face any time you're
like ah
i don't really want to film today you
know what i'm just like in a rut i
haven't uploaded in like a month i'm
going to take another week off
anytime you feel that come on we've all
felt that you got to redo the work by
steven pressfield
short it'll light your fires and kick
your tires
if you need to dip your dog and flip
your flop then that is the one
to uh to jump into um
we also this week in fact i'd encourage
you next
if you want to check out some more
practical
content that can help you grow listen to
the last
upload on the think marketing podcast we
interviewed the offer of author of hook
points
um brendan kane and uh super great book
and if you want to get like
a lot of value just for free listen to
the 30-minute conversation that we had
with brendan on
the think marketing podcast my name is
sean cannell
this is the coffee with cannell show
thanks for hanging out with me
first coffee with kennel of 2021 it's a
new year full of new opportunities and
new possibilities
we got to get focused there's so much
vitriol there's so much controversy
there's so much division
there's just so much stuff going on
everybody is vying for your attention
here's the bottom line man
cnn wants your attention that's how they
make money
fox news wants your attention
nbc wants your attention guess what hulu
netflix hbo max they want your attention
the playstation network and the xbox
network wants your attention
clubhouse wants you spending time on
clubhouse
it is up to you to figure out
how you're going to manage your time and
your
focus and i'll leave you with a quote
from dave ramsey that says live today
like no one else so later in life you
can live like no one else
there's something about managing your
focus with intense discipline today
so you can do whatever you want tomorrow
my friend
my friend peter voog said
entrepreneurship is living just a few
years of your life like no one else is
willing to
so that you can live the rest of your
life like a kid and doing whatever you
want
and he travels the world with his
friends santana
with his son santana and his wife he's
got passive income from rental
properties he's got
a business that is extremely lean and
mean and strategic
you had to do the work to get to that
place think media
multiple seven figure company a lot of
automation that gives me the time to do
what i want when i want
whenever i want listen if i want to hang
out on clubhouse
i get to guess what you get to too but
you could be delaying your dreams and
your destiny
because it's not the best use of your
time right
now live today like no one else live
today
like 99 of content creators and creative
entrepreneurs are not willing to because
they're so distracted and their focus is
so divided
be willing to have uncommon discipline
so that you can reach uncommon dreams
this has been coffee with cannell my
name is sean cannell hit the like button
if you got value today i appreciate you
so much and i'm excited to see you
in a future episode we'll talk soon